me
you were everything
[Music]
oh
she said
[Music]
my name is avita from geek culture in
singapore how are you olga you look so
beautiful thank you that's so kind thank
you very much i'm good how are you
i'm great thank you for asking i've
watched the movie three times in the
past week
with different people that's how much i
love it and every single time your
identity as taskmaster gets revealed
everyone's just completely shocked like
everyone didn't expect it to be antonio
people thought it was going to be like
someone else electric mason so i'm
curious to know was your role set in
stone from day one over there you know
changes along the way as to who you
would be playing
well i i only found out about it when
the offer came
so i was just uh i got the offer and
they said we'd like to offer you a
taskmaster and obviously um you know
it didn't take me very long to
do good thing i was super excited and
so yeah i don't know how long
for how long the studio was deciding
that i think it's it's a question to
that but yeah obviously i from the
moment i i knew that i'll be playing the
character i was just ecstatic it's so so
much fun
no i love that because the taskmaster we
got in the movie is completely different
from a test semester in the comics and
you did it so well how does it feel like
to be you know a major marvel villain
now
yeah it feels it feels great
it's exciting i mean it's also like you
know villains are always um they're
always very interesting to play in the
fact that there's always conflict and
you know what's
what's
usually what there is about villains and
it's definitely the case with uh with my
character is that there is uh it's not
just all black you know there is uh
she
there is there is a usually there is a
reason a reason why someone becomes a
villain um
most of the times um and it's it's
something to do with
with history with with the past with the
childhood probably most of it is in the
childhood and
um it's the you know psychological abuse
physical abuse that
children might suffer and you know you
realize with antonia she went through uh
quite a bit of that even though it's not
it's not
in depth explored there but uh
but there are hints and glimpse that you
see
but you see that underneath
it and when the spell goes off there is
a damaged human being who
who is also
who wants to love who wants to be loved
who is
capable of love probably but doesn't
know how we can all identify with that
and uh because we're all a mixture of
good and bad the character is complex
and i enjoy doing that so much to
to play with for sure now i know you've
been in plenty of action films before
black widow i know quantum and solas was
a really big hit and i know that you
actually got to perform some of your own
stunts in quantum so
how many stunts or did you get the
opportunity to form your own stunts in
black widow like how much of what we saw
is actually you
well you know you could see that that
thing is pretty complex
from crazy things i wish i could fly
like that
but i couldn't
so yeah that was um they were of course
i had uh stunt doubles uh and thank god
for them they were amazing and they make
my character look great um they were all
these skillful people you know gymnasts
martial arts everything that exists
because it's such a it's such a complex
uh
character that that can do everything
since
character mirrors the opponent
so basically there's nothing
then there's nothing that i can't do
yeah i've done i've done like some
things that lead it up to
obviously my revelation and so yes but
obviously most a lot of things were done
by
the eu the action was incredible i love
it that's why i've watched it so many
times and now i want to watch it again
you got me really excited to watch it
again
i'm impressed right
i love it i love the movie so much oh i
love this movie and that's all the time
i have a video today i'm so sorry but i
had such a lovely time meeting you and
please take care i'll see you again
[Music]
you